defense secretary lloyd austin said for
the first time he supports a major
change in how the military handles
sexual assault cases
in a statement austin said he will work
to finally end the scourge of sexual
assault and sexual harassment
in the military the change long resisted
by the pentagon would give independent
military lawyers
not military commanders responsibility
for handling sexual assault cases and
related crimes
but it needs congressional approval it
does in an exclusive cbs news report
last november
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor norah o'donnell spoke to soldiers
about the realities of the current
system
as part of a year and a half long
investigation
i faced immediate and consistent
retaliation after you reported
your assault you were stripped of your
rank
yes ma'am they were trying to break me
down they just go after you
because you're the victim and you're the
problem how many of you think there
needs to be
something massive that happens like a me
too movement for the military
all branches across the board all of us
need to be able to feel like we can
speak up
and that you're never alone and norah
o'donnell joins us now nora good morning
to you that was powerful reporting from
last year
how significant is this endorsement or
support from secretary austin
and what happens next it is
seismic this is the first head of the
pentagon
to hear from victims of sexual assault
and harassment
meet with them personally and then say
the first thing i'm going to do
while secretary is bring together an
independent commission to look into this
and report it
in 90 days he did that now he says he
agrees with the findings of the
independent commission
that the reporting and prosecution needs
to be handled by an
independent person not the commander
this is what survivors victims and their
families have been
advocating for for years they say this
is the change
that is needed in the military so that
more women
can serve in the military honorably so
that more women can advance
to those roles of commander and
leadership this
is seismic the change that it could
create if
congress goes along with what the
secretary of defense
has recommended he's going to be
testifying today in congress and he's
also expected to brief
the president about the findings of this
independent commission we'll be paying
attention to that nor did anything stand
out to you in the language that
secretary austin used to offer his
support
yes it's an excellent question there's
something to point out this is not just
about sexual harassment and assault
it is also about domestic violence and
in fact
this independent review commission
recommended that cases of domestic
violence
also be included in the independent
prosecution system
why the numbers are even higher than
sexual assault
there's a lack of transparency when it
comes to domestic violence
they don't even track uh domestic
violence in terms of in the military and
that is handled
by commanders if you are a victim
or a survivor of domestic abuse it gets
reported through the commander
and the reporting that we have done
specifically from advocates and lawyers
say look the reason you can't keep it in
the chain of command is because
the command in the military it's like a
family and i'm from a military family i
know this too
you know in many ways it's patriarchal
you view people that serve under you as
part of your family it's hard to believe
that they would be carrying out violence
or harassment or abuse
and so and also some of the data shows
when it comes to assault and harassment
almost half of victims say they were
told by their commanders to just
drop it and that's why there has been
this
push for a metoo movement in the
military where our reporting shows
that many of these survivors and victims
and families who have had
children who commit suicide say the
system has to change
it has to get out of the chain of
command there needs to be an independent
prosecutor and so
i think this is a watershed moment yeah
it's a big potential change
if congress acts or reporting on it has
been tremendous and we know you will
stay on it nora thank you very much
thank you tony